on va parler du classement des sportifs
français les mieux payés qui vient de
sortir on en a beaucoup parlé et le 20
heures de france 2 nous a dévoilé ce
classement 2018 est une belle année pour
antoine griezmann comblé par un titre
mondial avec l'équipe de france de
football et désormais détenteur d'un
record individuel celui du sportif
français le mieux rémunéré 33 millions
d'euros de revenu brut annuel
il devance kylie ann m mbappé et paul
pogba rhin grisou qui a valorisé
également son image par la pub aux 15
millions d'euros de salaire versé par
son club l'atletico madrid s'ajoutent
désormais 5 millions d'euros de contrats
publicitaires et 400000 euros de prime
après le titre mondial des bleus
d'ailleurs les 23 bleus du mondial sont
tous dans ce top 50 du classement des
plus gros salaires enfin où sont les
femmes
totalement absente de ce classement des
50 sportifs français les plus rémunérés
caroline garcia et la première d'entre
elles avec un million huit cent mille
euros de revenus en 2018 consolation
aucun tennisman de la devance donc en
tête griezmann fuyait maps et puis paul
pogba puis benzema fait batum pgo berre
est en attente très très très très très
loin alors pour voir arriver les dames
qu'est ce qu'on en pense c'est ce que
vous êtes choqué est ce que pas choqué
est ce que ce qui vous choque c'est
l'écart entre les hommes et les femmes
ludivine tiens oui moi c'est mais comme
d'habitude c'est toujours l'un de mes
combats c'est toujours ce que je trouve
le plus choquant c'est la beyoncé en
vous c'est le grand soir est exactement
celle à michelle obama de tout ça parce
que c'est c'est inadmissible pourquoi
les femmes longtemps le montant ne vous
choque pas c'est la différence entre les
hommes et les femmes pas les montants
choquent plus jeune étudiant on est au
courant on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent dans le sport et surtout
évidemment dans le seau d'eau où ils
m'ont et le mois comme ça tout va bien
sûr qu'on aimerait gagner autant de zèle
que moi j'en rêverai mais je les passe
et osez donc je m'en réjouis pour eux
mais je me réjouirais si en deuxième thé
en deuxième position s'il y avait une
somme oscillant classement dans un
paiement l'avenir pense est normal que
les femmes sont moins bien payés mais le
foot féminin raison ce serait normal
parce que le football masculin est plus
vendeur que le football féminin alors
dont les droits télé par exemple pour la
ligue 1 pour la période 2020 2024
c'est plus du milliard d'euros vous
rendez quoi vous vous dites de toute
façon comment il y ait un lien entre
leur salaire et ce qu'ils rappellent
exactement c'est pareil
normal que les footballeurs soient
rémunérés en fonction des revenus qu'il
génère est malheureusement tu as beau le
tableau va la faire ta fataliste mais en
l'occurrence il ya plus de personnes qui
s'arrache et mario de neymar que les
mario de martin qui est l'une des plus
grandes joueuses de football au monde à
la voile à la faute à qui mon chat la
photo télévision justement que nous ne
permettent pas de suivre les
compétitions de football féminin la
cheminée voilà vous êtes du repas de ce
soyons honnête lui lorsque l'on diffuse
un match de football féminin
même lorsque maintenant ça c'est rentrer
un peu plus dans les moeurs et même
lorsqu'ils rencontrent du succès au
mieux ils vont faire 2011 bien sûr sur
quelle chaîne toile et sur la tnt c'est
pas sur tf1 c'est parce que même si l'on
sait que sur tte la force face à bath
alors la carte du monde dedans l'argent
neuf accroche le 19 juin du monde de
football féminin centenaire de parent
est derrière nous bleu parce qu'en fait
ceci personne n y aura ni milou on y
sera et voilà et c'est aussi la faute
des chaînes de télévision qui n'offrent
pas la même visibilité alors qu'ils le
font pour le tennis féminin
oui alors moi les amis ça m'est
complètement égal que ce soit intel
intel intel qui touche même 100 millions
d'euros ce que je trouve pas normal
c'est le montant qui est versée alors
vous vous êtes rentré dans la logique
économique à fond ça veut dire vous dire
c'est normal il rapporte plus alors il
touche musetta c'est le marché je
voudrais juste vous dire un chiffre le
prix nobel aujourd'hui un prix nobel de
sciences ci touche un million d'euros
qu'est ce qu'ont apporté à l'humanité
griezmann mba par du pain et des jeux
comme halo mais il n'y a pas un seul
moment où la france est plus unie que
pendant la coupe du monde comme on a pu
le voir ces gars lequel rapport je suis
désolé qu'ils apportent au delà de ce
qu'ils rapportent financier mais on l'a
tous eu un léger temps je peux parler
pour les chaînes pour les marques pour
tout le monde
en plus de ça il nous apporte du bonheur
et le côté on s'en fout d'être black
blanc beur homo hétéro six garçons on
est tous ensemble on est là on est
derrière et c'est ce que vous avez
touché à la famille
[Applaudissements]
on a vu les foreuses à l'avant on a la
dernière fois on a vu des gens
descendent dans la rue ensemble et tout
comme aux usa les thalys est alors bien
ma vie vous êtes vous marcher sur la
tête mars à tout le monde qu'on h2 qu'on
a gagné c'est en 98 entre 98 et là on a
informé la dernière coupe du monde avant
celle ci ces 90 minutes et 2018 dans
pendant ses vingt ans ils ont tous
touché 20 millions d'euros ils nous ont
passé des cendres sur les champs elysées
c'est bien pour le cinéma
tu dois te souvenir aussi c'est qu'un
footballeur professionnel quand il
commence sa carrière quand il la
thermique sinon c'est que ça ils nous
sortent il ne peut rien construire sa
vie c'est le football et à 30 ans il a
plus de taf millions par an il a de quoi
voir venir
pas sûr que ça soit l'argument kitchen
mais bon j'ai envie de rentrer dedans
vous êtes choqués ou pas choquer vous
avez dit on leur a posé la question
parce auclair 38%
chuck et 68% en tout cas certains ne
sont pas aussi bien payé et je vous
cache pas qu'on comprend pourquoi
[Applaudissements]